مره اخرى كان الرد على مطالب المواطنين
اللبنانيين بالقنابل المسيله
ورغم ان اكثريه المتظاهرين الذين توافدوا
الى ساحه رياض الصلح كانوا من المتقاعدين
الا ان كبر السن لم يقف عائقا امام
استخدام القوه لمنعهم اجتياز الحاجز
المؤدي الى السراي
الحق بالطبابه والتعليم اضافه الى المطالب
المعيشيه التي زادها سوءا الانهيار
الصاروخي لليره اللبنانيه كانت الجامعه
بين مجموعات اختلفت انتمائها
سرقونا وسرقوا جنى عمرنا ومستقبلنا
ومستقبل اولادنا هولن لصوص اللي جوا انا
جاي شاري كطالب ثانوي انه اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر مدربين والوزير بعده غايب لا حلول
ولا شيء
وبالتزامن مع تحركات الشارع عقدت اللجان
النيابيه جلسه مناقشه لمسائله الحكومه
ومصرف لبنان وجمعيه المصارف عن الخطوات
التي فشلت باتخاذها
وفيما حضر ممثل عن رئيس الحكومه وحاكم
المصرف غابت جمعيه المصارف دون اي مبرر
لاحد اجوبه
انه انا اليوم اذا اضطريت اجي اذا ما رحنا
واضطريت اجي عندي عجز بالموازنه راح نكمل
طبع ميل طبعا
بالمجلس قلت له وقفت انا اعترض قلت له اول
شيء مش هيك بيحكى عن طباعه الليره
اللبنانيه لانه واحده من الاسباب الاساسيه
انهيار هو الطباعه اسهل شيء ندفع معاشات
القطاع الخاص اول شيء القطاع العام اول
شيء بتعيده هيكله القطاع العام تاني شيء
بتوقفوا التهريب بتحسنوا الايرادات
الموازنه لليوم اتقدمت ارتفاع سعر الصرف
بنسبه 12% خلال يوم واحد حرك الشارع
اللبناني لكن الدعوات الى الاضراب لم تلقى
اذانا صغيره ولم تلتزم الصيدليات بقرار
النقابه التي دعت الى الاغلاق احتجاجا على
عدم تسليم الشركات للادويه اما المصارف
وامام الارتفاع الصاروخي للدولار فتراجعت
عن اضرابها المفتوح الذي تشهره سلاحا في
كل مره يقف فيها القضاء بصف المدين هي
المطالب نفسها وحدت اكثر من مجموعه امام
السرايا الحكومي الذي يمثل حكومه ادارت
اذانها الصماء دون اتخاذ اي اجراء اصلاحي
يضع حدا لتعدديه سعر الصرف التي كانت سببا
اساسيا لضرب القدره الشرائيه غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت